matthew mcconaughey is an academy
award-winning actor
everybody knows and the founder of the
just keep living foundation
he joins us tonight thanks for being
here brett good to be here
what uh made you and your wife do this
uh
what what what's driving you here well
actually it was a
friend of mine roy spence um here in
austin and and i've been trying to keep
my pulse on
what's the message you know right now as
we go through this pandemic
and we started off about staying at home
and then it turned into
wear a mask and you know a few weeks ago
about a month ago
i could feel that this united purpose we
all have as americans to beat this enemy
uh in this virus that purpose got
hijacked a bit by partisan politics and
all of a sudden the narrative became
if you want to go to work you're on the
far right if you don't
want to go to work you want to stay home
you're on the far left and now even the
mask
wearing is getting politicized where if
you want to wear a mask you wear a mask
you're a liberal and if you don't you're
conservative and that's just not true
so this created a false divide sort of
two wars in the in a
in america an us versus them war and
then us versus the virus war
and you know if we try to fight both
those wars we're going to lose both of
them but if we try to fight the one
against the virus which is the one we
should be fighting then we're going to
beat it
so roy and i got together and said
ourselves and our families we need and
the nation need an authentic and
inspiring message to remind us let's
stay united in our purpose now
and beat this virus you know it is
interesting that that divide has
developed
in a partisan way obviously it's an
election year
and um and party politics factors into a
lot of things but
republicans i think it's fair to say
don't want to see people die
and democrats i think it's fair to say
don't want to see the economy falling
apart
how do you get that message through in
in this psa and what you're doing
yeah well part of it is saying just that
to remind us that this is not
about politics it's about us the usa
and we've got to take care of each other
right now we have a collective purpose
i mean how many times do we have a
unanimous are we unanimously convicted
of an enemy that we all want to be
and look at how great americans are when
purpose comes to us in a crisis look at
who we are in world war ii and we have a
crisis that came to us we were united in
that purpose
and all of a sudden the the human
factors started to get split
and two tribes started to fight each
other in partisan politics and that is
not what we need we need a collection
right now this is a tug of war with the
virus we need
all hands on the road if we're going to
beat it
i just want to remind everyone that
yeah and you you and your wife uh have
also donated a bunch
meals and laptops for kids in need and
and 200 000
face masks to front front-line workers
do you think that that's where this
solution comes from
charitable acts from around the country
do you think the federal government
is doing all it can
well i don't know if the federal
government government's doing all it can
uh all they can
i know they're doing a lot look i think
the word is not solution
i don't see a solution right now we are
we are waiting for signs to catch up
with us
in this predicament so what can each of
us do independently
individually in our families in our
households in our communities in our
neighborhoods in our cities
so act locally even this message this is
to the united states of america saying
hey
we're in this together now someone can
say yeah but it's a worldwide
pandemic yes it is get the message out
in your backyard
right now i don't think these are
solutions i think they're band-aids
to hold off until science catches up
until there's not two patients for every
one bed like there was in new york
until we see that an asymptomatic person
doesn't give it to someone who
who didn't have it so we can protect the
elderly especially and
and the younger ones um this is
unchartered waters there's not a
playbook i understand that
and uh these are band-aids and things we
need to do
to hold this off until we have enough
science to understand
that hey you know what we think it's
safe now to go re-engage
if you are going to reengage right now
plea please wear a mask
i haven't heard any science that says
that is not a good idea
and i hope we wear a mask as a badge of
honor and not something that we feel
like somebody told us we had to wear
it takes away our identity i i think
wearing a mask is not
propaganda i don't think it's
partisanship or politics
i think a mask is all about our purpose
right now again us as in the usa
to best beat this virus it's how we can
take care of ourselves
and others in the christ clearly
everybody's looking everybody the
chronovirus
it doesn't discriminate that the virus
doesn't care how we voted for
it yeah exactly uh i want to
end with this you're a sports fan you're
obviously university of
a texas fan you're also a washington
redskins fan
do you think sports is coming back well
i know it's coming back it's a matter of
when and how
you know we know it's coming back and uh
you know are we going to play games
without fans in the seats
are we going to play games with uh fewer
fans in the seats
separated by six or so feet are we going
to come back and fill stadiums i i
don't know when that's going to happen
but it will happen again that's another
thing we all need to remember
and let's just do our due diligence
until we get there and then we can go
pack the houses again
and have a hundred thousand people
watching the great american sport of
football
hey matthew thanks a lot thanks for what
you're doing and we appreciate you
coming on
appreciate it thanks for having me brett
you bet